okay I have to say first of all the
squad that can't happen
that cannot be a thing I am I forbid it
I will not allow it I do not permit it
we are not it is it's just the squad No
okay the these are the group of freshmen
Democrats Cortez Omar Talib Presley have
somehow adopted this name the squad and
and the media is just going with it of
course and it's it putting it in
headlines and news reports and everyone
even conservatives are going with it
okay we're going to call them the squad
now it is just so corny and lame and bad
and and and not good that I can't I I
can't stand it
I mean the squad sounds it sounds like a
pop group that would have tried out on
the x-factor back in 2005 or something
it sounds like or maybe more like a like
a girl group from 1998 that had one hit
and then one you know kind of minor hit
and then they disappeared from the face
of the earth there are much cooler names
that they could have chosen how about
something like the contingent or the
faction or the coalition you know those
are all corny too but slightly less so
that's all I can say is if we're doing
the squad thing then III hope that a
group of Young Republicans get together
and form a group called the clique and
then of course the clique and the squad
will have break dance competitions on a
bi-monthly basis okay so there's that's
just at my Edna at this point now that's
that's my that's my dream actually we're
not far from that I this isn't really a
breakdance competition but I just saw
that Joe Biden said today or maybe it
was yesterday
that if he is if he's the nominee and
he's challenged at a debate by Trump on
his age and his mental agility he will
challenge Donald Trump on the spot to a
push-up competition he actually said
that
and so this
I mean I really hope that Biden's
nominee in that case because I I I have
no doubt that Biden actually would
challenge Trump to a push-up competition
and I think if Trump is challenged that
he's not gonna be able to say no so
we're gonna get that spectacle of two
men in their 70s doing a push-up
competition and so I'm I'm on board for
that all right so a couple things here
there's something from yesterday that's
getting a lot of attention and something
else that's not getting as much
attention but I think it should be
flipped I think the thing that's not
getting as much attention should be
getting more than the other thing so the
first thing the thing that everyone's
focusing on is the press conference that
was held by the Spice Girls I'm sorry
there's a wrong girl group the the the
squad they held a press conference to
respond to Trump's tweets the tweets
that we discussed at length yesterday on
the show we don't need to get into that
again they made a lot of accusations
against Trump many of those accusations
especially the ones from Omar are were
false or misleading she said for example
among among other false accusations she
said that Trump she accused Trump of
calling people from other countries s
holes well no that's wrong he called the
other countries s holes and there but
there's a very clear difference between
saying that about a country and saying
it about a person from that country so
that's just one example of something
that she lied about and in fact I've
been told that I don't wanna get into
the tweets again but people have been
telling me that you'll you see that this
is why Trump this is why Trump tweeted
that to begin with that's why this is
why the tweet was a genius ploy on his
private part because he prompted them to
get up at a press conference and tell a
bunch of lies and embarrass themselves
so you see it all worked out for him
well I'm not sure that giving your enemy
is a forum to lie about you is really a
win for you short to those of us who are
already right-wing we're gonna see a
press conference with the Spice Girls
and we're going to think that it's
embarrassing
and everything but not everybody is a
committed right winger and my whole
point that I was trying to make
yesterday is that you know if Trump is
focused just on appealing to the most
committed and and sort of entrenched
right wingers in the country he's gonna
lose you need more than that there
aren't enough of those to win there
especially aren't enough of those in
places like Pennsylvania and and in
Michigan those states that he really is
gonna need to win again all right so no
I don't think that the Prescott even
though from my perspective the press
conference was a disaster for that for
them that doesn't actually mean that it
was in the in the minds of the people
that you need to appeal to for me as a
as a far less are right for hunt because
I am a far left well I criticized Trump
that makes me a far leftist Freudian
slip there as a far-right extremist
myself anytime Cortes or Omar or one of
the Spice Girls says anything I to me
it's embarrassing because these people
are so absurd but what I have to realize
is that I am seeing things through a
lens that not everybody shares so not
everyone is looking at it like front of
the way that I am okay so that was the
press conference there was a moment at
the press conference where Omar was
asked to respond to another Trump tweet
wherein he accused her of being Pro al
Qaeda and she refused to deny the charge
she she said she wasn't going to dignify
it with an answer so she didn't say no
I'm not pro al Qaeda come on she just
said she's not gonna dignify it with an
answer this again is a moment that
conservatives are making a big deal
about saying oh look she's at you she's
not denying it but and I agree that
again from my perspective that's a very
embarrassing moment for her and
troubling one for the country but I
don't think it's gonna be a problem for
Omar I think she can get away with
acting like it's such an absurd question
and such an insulting question that
she's not going to dignify
with an answer in the same way that if a
reporter asked Trump are you pro-nazi or
are you Pro KKK I think that he could
and probably should answer I'm not gonna
ask that question like I dig 'no phi
that with an answer so i think that a
lot of people are gonna see it in this
sort of the same vein the al-qaida
moment that's gonna get a lot of play on
fox news and stuff but i don't think
it's gonna make waves outside of
right-wing circles and for the record I
think Omar obviously doesn't want to
talk about Muslim violence she doesn't
want she she wants to minimize it as she
did famously with some people did some
things which is how she described 9/11
and that is morally abominable on her
part but I don't think she's a Muslim
fundamentalist herself she herself is
not a you know Sharia law loving Muslim
and I know that because she's a
left-wing radical that's what she is you
can't really be both those are the two
diametrically opposed viewpoints so you
can't be both they're only similar in
being extreme but other than that that's
where the similarities end
oh and they but and and in both cases
you're gonna hate Christians so I mean
you have those two things in common
which I do think is why radical left
leftist do have some sympathy for Muslim
fundamentalist even though the Muslim
fundamentalists would kill them the
radical leftist but they have some
sympathy because both of them it's kind
of enemy on my enemy sort of thing so
they do have that account but other than
that the ideologies are worlds apart
literally but there was something else I
think this this brings us remember oh ma
r is a radical left winger the same for
Cortes same for Presley's in fur to lead
and that brings us to the to the moment
which i think is a much bigger deal this
wasn't at the press conference but I
guess it was walking from it or going to
it the squad members were were I can't
even
without the squad they were asked very
directly if they condemn ante foe and
especially if they condemn the terrorist
attack carried out by in antifoam member
at a government facility just this past
weekend now mr can act like questions
about al-qaida are too absurd to answer
she can't do that with this because an
Tifa is a radical left-wing group she is
a radical leftist it is a perfectly
valid and important question to ask and
it is something that she obviously needs
to condemn so let's see how this moment
goes and this this by the way is a
journalist who you can find on Twitter
at the real keen ke EA n is out of
spelled I want to give him a shout out
because I think he did great work here
and he's asking a question that of
course no one in the mainstream media is
gonna ask so we'll go through he got to
I'm not sure if he got to the fourth
member but he asked Omar al C and
Presley if they would condemn aunt Eva
and here how here how those moments went
first let's uh let's watch omar Antipa
fire bombed a facility in tacoma over
the weekend it's an ice facility will
you condemn them for that I mean can
fire bombing a concentration camp is
kind of a laudable thing if it actually
is a concentration camp you must be
happy that they did it no are you
pleased should more people do it it's
easy to say no it's really easy to say
no okay so you see her kind of smiling
and giggling there a little bit she
didn't she wouldn't she refused to
condemn now here is a Oh see will you be
condemning auntie [ __ ]
they firebombed an American facility
will you condemn them
[Music]
will you be condemning them do you feel
like you have some responsibility in the
attack with your rhetoric about
concentration camps are you responsible
do you feel ashamed
okay here's Presley will you tell
Americans not to attack violently ice
facilities just say no it would be a
very simple thing to say and it would go
a long way to tell Americans that you're
not sympathetic to Antipa are you
sympathetic to Antipa why is it a hard
thing for you to say are they your base
are you worried that they're not gonna
vote for you are you ashamed at all I
mean this this is a pretty simple answer
so there there you go there you go
that's the moment or those are the
moments I should say that need to be
amplified and shown everywhere that this
is what we should be talking about
because this question was not like some
kind of cheap gotcha question it's not
an absurd question
this isn't like excuse me congresswoman
do you support cannibalizing the elderly
excuse me
answer the question why won't you answer
the question no that's not with it this
is a legitimate and fair question and
Tifa again is a left-wing terror group
and they are now staging attacks on ice
facilities which Cortez has described as
concentration camps so it is obviously
important that IOC and the other members
of the Spice Girls stand up and condemn
this and and urge their followers not to
be a part of this kind of thing and Tifa
also was out a few weeks ago smashing
people in the head with crowbars as I
said a few weeks ago you can and and
very pathetically some liberals have
tried to defend in Tifa by saying well
they haven't killed anybody yet
they haven't yet either look let's
compare the the death toll white
nationalists versus antiva yes they
haven't killed anybody but it's not for
lack of trying
they have tried to they just haven't
successfully done it yet when you hit
somebody in half of the crowbar you're
trying to kill them if they survive it's
only because you are such an effeminate
weakling that you can't even pitch you
could hit somebody with a crowbar and
they still all they end up with is a
bump in that I mean you know you give a
four-year-old a crowbar and give him a
couple swings at someone's head they'll
probably kill him
so I just shows you how weak and
ridiculous these people are but still
they're they're dangerous they even even
these people with with you know biceps
the size of toothpicks when you give
them a credit they they're still
dangerous and now that they've graduated
to guns and explosives what does it
matter how weak you are when you're
shooting a gun at somebody you could
kill them so they're still very
dangerous and they are terrorists yet
you have aoc and the others refusing to
condemn and notice I think it was able
to see who said something like of
they're all issue a statement or
whatever well she still hasn't issued a
statement but that's the kind of thing
so again this was not their response was
not a sort of I'm not gonna dignify that
of course I condemn I'm not gonna even
talk about that wasn't their response
their response was they didn't want to
talk about it at all to say to refuse to
talk about it say I'll issue a statement
that's what you do when this is a topic
you don't want to go anywhere near but
as the questioner said this is very easy
I mean just to condemn terrorism to
condemn shooting at a government
facility to condemn smashing people in
head with crowbars that should be a very
easy thing to do it's not a trick
question all you have to say is I
condemn it absolutely this cannot happen
the people who did it should be
prosecuted to the full extent of the law
they won't say it
why won't they say it well the thing is
when you get when you're silent in a
matter like this you leave everyone else
to fill in the blanks because you've
given a silence so we can only assume we
can only speculate and my speculation
which i think is totally accurate is
that they're silent about it because
they agree
well there are two reasons one is and
both are very troubling and disturbing
one is they know that a large section of
their base consists of radical leftists
who are either in an Tifa or are very
sympathetic to Aunt Eva so they know
that they don't want upset their base
also on a personal level I believe they
totally agree with what aunt Eva does
they're fine with it from their
perspective if you disagree with them
then you're a bigot you're a racist
you're a homophobe you're a Nazi your
fascist your KKK you're all of those
things rolled up into one you don't
deserve to live I mean you you you have
no right to anything you are utter scum
and your life is meaningless that's the
perspective that these people have and
you would have to have that perspective
if you're at all hesitant to stand up
and say listen I disagree with the the
people who are being attacked by antifa
but no of course you shouldn't smash
them and head with a crowbar if you're
at all hesitant or reluctant to say that
then that means that you must agree that
you must think that these people deserve
to be smashed with crowbars or to be
shot at so this is where we are it's
very it's it's I mean it's it's
horrifying and it may I mean just
imagine if and when these people control
the country again if they get somebody
in the White House one of their one of
their own in the White House given their
opinion about us those who disagree with
them given that they feel that we
deserve to be hit in head with crowbars
and to be shot at and to be killed I
mean you could just imagine what happens
when they're in control
alright by the way quick history lesson
from Joe Biden this is a this is history
101 with Joe Biden watch this
there has never been a president in
American history
and have so openly racist and aggressive
is this man imagine what it says the
United States is always led by the
example of our power and from this
president after
and Charlotte's continuing chair wasn't
loaded go home to Brooklyn you know I
mean go home to Michigan to hold their
cultures it's sickening it's impacts
the most racist president in American
history yeah in American history he's
the most racist president that is just
the kind of statement that and you know
many of his supporters are going to hear
that it's a yeah that's right most
racist ever I mean you have to be so
ignorant of American history to make a
statement like that I could point to so
many but just one example Abraham
Lincoln said that black people are
inferior to white people he opposed
legal and social equality explicitly and
said so and he proposed sending black
people back to Africa okay these were
all things that he explicitly said now
he's a you're telling me that that's
less racist than any tweet that Trump is
show me a trump to eat that's a more
racist racist than that and that's just
what I mean
really any president for the first you
know 100 plus years of of American
history was certainly extremely racist
meanwhile as I said yesterday even
though I think Trump's what tweet was
stupid I don't think that he's racist I
think that he just is he says whatever
is gonna get him attention and he and he
and he you know if you criticize him
then he hates your guts if you
compliment him he loves you and that
that's what he decides that that's how
he judges people it's got really had
nothing to do with race all right um so
let's move away from politics for a
minute I've been wanting to talk about
this the live-action Lion King okay this
is a more important subject the
live-action Lion King remake comes out I
guess it comes out this weekend right
came out in China last weekend comes out
this weekend here of course it's being
referred to as live-action but it's not
really live-action because it's still a
movie about talking lions so this is
these are they didn't train real lions
to talk for the movie and to sing songs
it is a it is a cartoon still this is a
cartoon remake of a cartoon it's just a
slightly more realistic
cartoon because of course the original
Lion King was great but the one thing
holding it back from being really really
great and from you really enjoying it is
that the singing warthog didn't look
enough like a real warthog right isn't
that when you're watching the when you
watch the original Lion King isn't that
what you always think tears up I know
this Pumbaa character I mean if only he
looked more realistic I think I'd really
be able to enjoy this more now I'm sure
the movie this movie the new Lion King
is going to make 15 quadrillion movies
dollars at the box office because these
movies always do but the reviews have
been actually lukewarm which is good I
think but surprising good because these
lifeless charmless pointless redundant
cash grabs should be recognized as such
but kind of and condemned as such in my
view but kind of surprising because
usually critics don't recognize when
something is a redundant pointless
charmless lifeless cash grab that that's
why you know almost every Marvel
superhero movie that comes out gets
glowing reviews they all they all get
like 98% on Rotten Tomatoes even though
they're all exactly the same nothing new
or interesting has been done with it
with a superhero movie since the Dark
Knight you know back whatever was 10
years ago and for a decade there's just
been nothing interesting or new adds
just the same thing over and over and
over again
critics always love it in this case
though it seems like maybe some of them
are final I mean this is what they do
for a living right they they criticize
movies they critique movies I should say
for a living they should be able to
recognize when something is just when
something exists just to make money and
for no other reason maybe finally
they're waking up to it now this Lion
King remake is just the latest Disney
remake of a Disney film that came out
less than three decades previous there's
also been buting the beast of course and
Aladdin and Little Mermaid and and
they're coming out with Mulan they're
gonna have a Mulan live-action remake
they did Cinderella already I think they
did Alice in Wonderland they did Dumbo
so some of those are older Disney movies
originally now I call these remakes
and that's what everyone calls it
they're not really remakes they are
reenactments they are with a few
exceptions I think Alice in Wonderland
Dumbo is they actually did something
different with them but with the rest of
them these are just reenactments these
are shot-for-shot reenactments for the
most part mirror copies of the original
films same characters same lines same
songs same everything it just beat for
beat the exact same thing I mean The
Lion King even hired some of the
original voice actors to play the same
cartoon again which makes you wonder why
even do that why not just take the
original dialogue from yours and move
and dub it into the the new movie
hey why how about a remake where it's
just literally the same movie again this
is nothing has changed at all not even
the animation you just re-release it and
call it a remake because that's that's
what this is the original
okay the original movies what we
consider to be the original movies those
are the remakes all of these stories of
course already existed most of them are
based on old fairy tales Lion King is
kind of a hamlet and Bambi mashup of
course the Beauty and the Beast is an
old story
these are remakes in the sense that the
90s versions are remix in the sense that
they took existing stories existing
ideas and they they kind of did their
own thing with them oftentimes taking
darker and more mature stories and
making them into kind of funny
kid-friendly musicals which is cool
buting the Beast was originally written
in the 18th century I believe it's a
18th century French
fairy tale the Beauty and the Beast from
from Disney in the 90s takes this old
dense mature French tale and turns it in
this beautifully animated whimsical
family movie now that's what a remake is
because that takes imagination and wit
and creativity where you're taking the
original things and it's not a carbon
copy you're just you're you're basing
your version on this version you're
inspired by it and then you do your own
thing with the wit with sort of the the
elements of the story
these new things though they just attach
themselves to the 90s versions
parasitically and try to profit off them
without doing anything new or
interesting whatsoever it's just it's
just a it's it's just for the profit and
no other reason and that's why I resent
it I resent even more that people still
go and mindlessly consume this garbage
at Disney just shovelling into your
mouth because they have no respect for
you as a viewer I I went on to a whole
thing last week about how I think the
boycotts are stupid we should be
boycotting so much everyone's boycotting
everything well so I'm not talking about
here about a Disney I'm not promoting or
proposing a Disney boycott it's more
just we should recognize that Disney
they ran out of new ideas decades ago
they're not even trying anymore
and now they're just shuffling this
garbage into your mouth maybe we should
stop eating it I mean when they have so
little respect for their viewers that
they're going to just give you the exact
same movie again with the only
difference is it's just it's it's less
whimsical and less creative we shouldn't
go out and give them a billion dollars
in return it's just self-respect is what
I'm talking about here think about what
they could have done with this latest
round of movies they could do what they
did the first time
not literally exactly what they did the
first time which is what they're doing
now but they could take the stories and
and and just do another variation
another take I mean even the original
buting the beast the real original the
one from the 18th century even that
isn't really original because at its
core right it's a story about a
beautiful person learning to love an
ugly person and that love bringing out
the beauty in that ugly person it's a
story about the elevating edifying power
of love GK Chesterton I believe it was
who said that the lesson of Yuting the
beast is that a thing must be loved in
order to be lovable the point is that
love lifts us up brings us up ok so
that's that's what the beauty beauty the
beast the story is about the late in
there there is there's hundreds of
stories out there that all center around
that truth and many of the stories are
whether it's a book or a movie you can
tell that basic story a million times in
a million different ways and it could be
compelling every single time it's just
that you can't tell in exactly the same
way that it's already been told you
should do your own thing
because there are a million different
ways of telling that basic truth the
latest meeting the Beast could have told
that story could have focused on that
truth truth in a different way I just
said truth I did I can't get around it
could have focused on that truth in a
different way telling a different but
still fun and memorable and
family-friendly story that would be
interest that would be worthwhile but
instead they just took the 90s version
and just did the exact same thing they
they're doing basically cover versions
of the 90s versions which in fact not
even cover versions because I mean the
great cover songs you think about Jeff
Buckley's hallelujah or Janis Joplin's
me and Bobby McGee and any of the great
cover version cover songs what they do
is is they're always distinct from the
original they take the original song
they do the original scent but they
bring something different out of it you
think about Johnny Cash's cover of Trent
Reznor's hurt it's it's like a totally
it sounds like it's Johnny Cash's sorry
it sounds like it's a song that he wrote
about himself he makes it his own as
they say in the musical singing shows
and he just does his own thing and it
becomes a story about him about this old
man at the end of his life who's
thinking back on his regrets and so on
that's um that's what a that's what a
good cover song is these Disney's new
Disney movies are not good cover songs
they are more like karaoke cover songs
they are just it's exactly the same as
the original but just worse without the
spontaneity without the surprise without
the talent without the depth without
anything just just a dumbed down
bland or version of what we already saw
and so I'm just saying we should we
should stop dignifying this stuff with
our money let me get I'll a move on a
second but one so I over the weekend
with my kids I watched
just because I mean I feel like I can
watch a preview and I can read a
description of a movie and nine times
out of 10 I already know if it's good or
not I don't actually need to watch it I
just already tell so I do that with
these Disney movies I get are I don't
need I don't need to go and watch the
new Aladdin I can tell it's garbage
there's no chance it's not garbage I
already know that I don't need to watch
it but I said yeah maybe I should watch
one of these just so I can say that I
did so I could be fair about it
so I with my kids I watched the the
latest Beauty the Beast the live-action
Beauty and the Beast which I hadn't seen
before
of course like anyone else I grew up
with the original Beauty the the
original and the 90s I liked it as a kid
of course and so I watched it and it was
exactly what I thought it was just it
was just like the whole time I'm
thinking why are we watching this we
could just put the cartoon on it's so
much better it's just this is what's the
point of this other than to make money I
understand that but what's the point of
me watching it I'm not profiting off of
it
there was one there's one scene in the
in the new buting the Beast because
there are a few different they do make a
few changes but the changes that they
make in these live-action things the
changes are usually just it's not
creative changes not that they're
improving or they're doing their own
thing it's just that they have to they
they have to do certain things to
compensate for the fact that it's not a
cartoon anymore so there's one scene I
think perfectly encapsulates the problem
with these live-action reenactments
there's a scene in in the 90s Beauty the
Beast where Gus Gaston goes to propose
the Belle right in the beginning the
movie he goes and it goes to her house
barges and proposes in his way she
shoots him down she's pretty rude about
it frankly
and then she basically shuts him out the
door and he falls into a big puddle of
mud and then somehow there's a pig that
ends up on top of his head and he
brought his little henchmen along with
him whether his name is and also a
marching band because he expected he
would go in propose she would say yes
you come out the marching band would
play and celebrate and they get married
that day doesn't go that way he ends up
in the mud pig on the head okay now I've
watched that movie with my kids it gets
a laugh every time from the kids a funny
to nish because it's a cartoon wacky
silly kind of scene well I guess in the
live-action version they figured they
can't really do that because it's with
real people it would just look too
ridiculous to have him in the mud with a
pig on his head
a real pig it just thought he wouldn't
look right so instead it's the same
basic scene but instead it's just he
goes he proposes she says no and then he
just walks blandly away and as he's
walking away he steps in a puddle of mud
briefly and kind of shakes it off his
shoe and keeps walking that's the change
so that's that's the create that's the
oh that's that's worth a billion dollars
right that change you take this fun
silly scene and you turn it into
something boring that's those are the
only changes made for these movies and
so again I believe that we should not a
boycott this is a call for self-respect
and we're just saying to Disney we're
not gonna keep watching this garbage
give us something new okay we have
standards we're not just gonna we need
art you know movies are expensive we got
other things we could spend our money on
I'm just gonna go just gonna hand over
40 bucks to you so you can just give me
that yeah you got to give me something
better all right let's move on to emails
Matt well show at gmail.com Matt wall
show at gmail.com this is from Andy says
I think it's funny how you think that
Trump is more racist than Democrats I
won't bother describing your fallacy
sorry you had no you had to experience
such humiliation today pick up a book
every once in a while the Democrats will
never not own racism in America you know
history proves you wrong
don't bother replying and please don't
humiliate yourself on air again you'll
only regret it please don't reply for
your own sake yes because that's I spoke
probably for 30 minutes on this going
into great detail about the my
perspective on this trying to try to
explain my point in probably too much
detail and that's what Andy that's what
detective Andy that's what insightful
Andy takes away is that I said that
Trump is more racist than the Democrats
with it that's what that way he takes
from this I
people who there's a and it's there's a
thing these days with people that I I
just I can't wrap my head or I don't get
it
wouldn't when you can convey your point
very clearly you can even repeat your
point as I tend to do ten or fifteen
times just going back to it here's my
point there's my point here's like one
and someone can listen to that and still
miss the point I it possible especially
for me I repeat myself so much how could
you possibly miss my point I'm like
hitting you over the head with it like
I'm a nutiva member with a crowbar I'm
hitting here's my point are you
listening to me and still people like
Andes are good I understand your point
oh so you think Trump is racist I said
exactly the opposite Andy okay um I mean
I literally said I was like a seven
minute digression yesterday where I said
no I don't think Trump's racist and then
I explained why I don't think he's
racist and Andy hears that so you think
Trump is racist
good lord Andy for your sake I'm going
to assume that you are raging alcoholic
and you were completely drunk when this
show aired yesterday and that's why you
you missed the point I'm for your saying
I'm gonna I'm gonna see the best in you
and assume that's what happened this is
from Phil says I agreed with you on your
podcast yesterday until I talked with a
number of my Republican friends they all
feel Trump's weekend tweets were
intentional and brilliant
he forced Pelosi to stand with the squad
and move to the radical left the own
that only benefits the Republicans well
Phil yes I'm sure your Republican
friends did say that but the problem
again is it's not your Republican
friends that I think are the issue here
yet Republicans are going to committed
Republicans are most the time gonna side
with Trump going to see the best and
everything he does and says and you know
are going to try to spin it in the most
positive way that's what Republicans are
going to do
fine right but not not everyone's a
Republican and there aren't enough
committed active Republicans to get you
re-elected you're gonna need to appeal
to other people as well
now of course far left Democrats you're
not going to get them there's no point
in even trying not saying that I'm just
saying you also need to be able to
appeal to people who are not necessarily
totally committed to the right-wing
agenda right and so the opinion of
people who are committed to that agenda
isn't really relevant to this discussion
because of course we already know what
they're gonna say about a Trump thing I
also think look he forced Pelosi just an
not unified them it's not that they're
all standing around
Ilhan Omar it's not the point they're
all they're they're all just standing
around together talking about how racist
Trump is that's the unity and I just I
don't see how that benefits him
it just it's at best you could say he
won't be harmed by it maybe he won't but
it's it's not a benefit if that's not
better than what was happening last week
when they were all fighting with each
other that was better
okay from from anonymous I enjoyed your
show until yesterday now I can't listen
anymore you've lost a fan and follower
you've revealed yourself to be an
unamerican liberal in disguise f off
again this is another another very
intuitive person who could listen to all
that and yeah of course because that's
everyone knows it's not even look
anonymous it's not even a disguise I
mean everyone knows that I am a far left
liberal it's I I think I'm well known
for that I don't hide it I don't
disguise it it's just it's I'm I think
I'm I think if I'm known for anything I
have to say I think I'm known for being
a liberal which is why I my inbox all
the time is filled with glowing reviews
from liberals it's constantly they're
always emailing me to tell me what a
great guy I am and hey they wish good
fortune and health on myself and my
family it's all the time because I am
such a liberal so a great great point
and yes if you criticize a politician
then you're unamerican that's a
great perspective you know it's not like
that perspective is itself disgustingly
unamerican no no you're right because
that's it's it's loving America is not
about loving America it's just about
loving Trump right Trump is America
Trump is God Trump Trump is everything
Trump is life and if you criticize him
even a little bit then you're unamerican
you're terrible you're awful f off I'm
never gonna listen to you that's a great
great I mean let me tell you something
you're not at all in an embarrassing
sycophantic cultist when you have that
perspective not at all this is from
Brittany says hello Matt I desperately
need advice about my mother-in-law she
is kind-hearted giving but completely
lacking a sense of self-awareness aren't
they all
and doesn't respect boundaries it's a
strange combination my husband and I
have gotten by and dealt with her weird
and sometimes manipulative antics but
now having two young children
complicates it the most recent issue we
let my oldest three three years old
spend the night with her this weekend
and go to church with her on Sunday I'm
admittedly a bit of a control freak when
it comes to my kids I prefer the term
high standards and my mother-in-law has
a habit of never listening to anything
we tell her so I had a very hard time
allowing this she lets my three-year-old
run the show she also gets an idea in
her head and will call us 15 times to
say we need to change how we do things I
wrote out very specific notes for her
most of them pertaining to the digestive
issues my daughter has I told her about
bedtime nap time the next day I told her
we don't want we don't mind if she goes
to church with them but we don't want
her to sit in the sanctuary not go to
the nursery
my daughter stayed with us at our church
so she's perfectly capable of that or we
want her to say the sanctuary not go to
the nursery okay I'm sure you're smart
enough to see where the story is going
she did literally the opposite of
everything we said I mean every single
thing she went to bed at midnight she
ate all of the foods that I told her
mess up her stomach she went to the
Merton nursery at church she didn't take
a nap I was livid I'm looking for advice
on how to deal with this I want to
confront her right then and there but
decided it was wisest not to my mom but
my husband and I have decided the next
time she asked to babysit or have a
sleepover we will tell her no because we
can't trust you to respect our wishes I
don't
want to keep my kids away from their
grandparents but I also know I can't
trust them to follow our rules there's
so much more to but I can't tell you all
of the woes in an email please give me
some advice on how in the world I should
deal with this crazy lady that is my
mother-in-law
well Brittany you're you probably won't
like probably won't like my answer and
let's begin with my answers basically
irrelevant because I'm no more of an
expert on how to deal with
mother-in-law's than you are so there's
no reason why whatever I have to say you
should trust more than your own
intuition but since you asked for it I'm
always eager to get my opinion on
everything so I I tend to think and this
is something you know comes up with us I
think comes up with everybody right I
tend to think that this is just what
grandparents do it's just what they do
they let the kids stay up they give them
junk food they you know whatever they
let them watch but it's just this is
what this is the grandparent thing it's
sort of there's no way around it you
can't avoid it
and so in in my situation in our family
I tend to be my wife is a little bit
more like you she's she's less relaxed
about it and she you know she feels like
look this is what we want for our kids
or our kids you should follow our rules
I tend to say yeah you know what we're
giving them the grandparents they're
watching them so maybe we should as long
as here's here's my thing as long as
it's something truly dangerous is not
happening okay obviously if your
mother-in-law is putting your kids in
danger in some way then that's a problem
and you need to talk about it and you
probably shouldn't let her watch the
kids anymore
but if she's just being the grandmother
or spoiling the kids letting them stay
up and all that I mean I did that with
my when I that's why I loved visiting my
grandmother when I was a kid it's
because yes she would let us stay up as
long as we wanted we could watch
whatever he wanted on TV she would just
she would just shove sweets and junk
food in our mouths constantly and it was
great and so I think that that's it's
almost like you I feel like I'd be
depriving
our kids if we don't allow them to have
that relationship with their
grandparents when that's what
grandparents are supposed to do it's not
really a big deal it's not like she's
undoing everything you've done they said
send them to the nursery or whatever
well all the work you've done to make
sure the kids can sit in the church it's
not undone by that one experience so
that would be my I tend to be more
relaxed about it and I would say yeah
you're yes you have your rules but also
at the same time when you're entrusting
your kids to someone else really it's
it's their rules they're the ones
watching your kid you're not there so in
some ways their rules are going to
supersede your own because they are the
ones watching them you know that's
that's it's like if you send your kid to
daycare and the kid might say well at
home my mommy lets me do this and that
well the daycare provider is gonna say
okay well you're not at home though and
and I'm in charge right now and in in in
in our situation we don't do that and I
think as parents when we entrust our
kids to someone else our job is to say
to our kids look they're the mommy and
daddy for right now as far as you're
concerned listen to them their rules go
of course there are in extreme
circumstances you might have to step in
and your rules are going to supersede
again if someone is being put in danger
but I don't think you can give your kids
to someone else and then expect that
everything is going to happen exactly as
you do it in your own home and the last
thing I'll say is I 10 my my kids have
their grandparents on both sides of the
family fortunately that are all alive
still and they're all very helpful they
watch the kids all the time and I tend
to be very grateful for that
and so I also think that sometimes
there's a lack of gratitude when we try
to be too controlling about how our kids
are cared for
when grandparents are stepping in to
help us out sometimes it comes off as a
lack of grad
- we should be grateful you know the
fact is your mother-in-law was taking
the kid for a night so that you could go
out with your husband right and have a
date night do whatever you wanted to do
so I think your first reaction should be
well I'm really grateful if she didn't
have to watch him
it's Alex you're doing her a favor by
letting her watch the kids she's you
know she does want to see the kid but
really she's doing you a favor first and
foremost all right um let's do one one
more this is from Henry says hi Matt
first of all thank you for being a voice
of reason on the ocean of insanity that
we live in today your show is the best
daily wire podcast by far and I agree
with most of what you say except that
God exists that's quite a it's quite a
stipulation so I'd like to know what are
your top three or more books that you
would recommend an atheist read except
for the Bible greetings from Brazil
Henry thanks so much for listening to
the show and I appreciate that you
listen even though we differ on this
obviously fundamental question so you
you didn't specify I assume you mean
water books I recommend that you read
that will help you get an understanding
of my belief system and why I think God
exists I assume that's what you mean not
just books in general but specifically
spiritual or theological books okay so
as far as that goes
I would so okay three I would recommend
well first I would recommend if you want
to understand Christian theology what we
actually believe at a basic level then I
think mere Christianity is a good place
to start now mere christianity but by CS
lewis of course is it's a very simple
book and so you're not going into
complex theological concepts i'll get to
that in a minute but i think this is a
good entry point just to give you as I
said a basic understanding of what most
Christians believe across all the
denominations and why they believe it
that would be my first recommendation
then I would recommend something by
Dostoevsky I I'll go with crime and
punishment I think is his most his
easiest one to read his most accessible
which isn't to me a might say easy read
I just mean that it kind of moves
quicker and and it just you get its its
it's his closest thing to a real
page-turner that you just can't put down
his other books are great but they have
denser parts that are harder to get
through sometimes so I would recommend
crime and punishment that I think
although it's a novel it's it's it's not
an explicitly theological or apologetic
work it still is giving you a lot of
Christian philosophy it's going to give
you a real insight into that so I'd
recommend crime and punishment and then
finally if you're looking to really be
intellectually challenged and you want
something I don't know where you're at
you know in terms of you know your what
kind of books you normally read but if
you're looking for something that's a
little bit more scholarly and and and
denser that's gonna really get into the
weeds of Christian theology then I would
recommend something by Alvin Plantinga
and in Richard and/or Richard Swinburne
and really anything I just Google those
two names pick anything and read one of
them so that's what I would I would say
start there and then once you've done
that come back if you're still
interested I could give you three more
books three and you know what here's
what I'll say too because people ask me
for reading recommendations all the time
I'm always happy to give them if you
want to give me three books of your own
not of your own that you wrote but three
books as an atheist that you think are
very compelling and and make a great
argument and that will give me an
insight into your point of view then
feel free to offer those and I will I'll
read them okay we'll leave it there
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed today on the Ben
Shapiro show President Trump at war with
the squad that's today on the bench
Shapiro show